joyeux anniversaire joyeux anniversaire
ne cherchait pas les bougies je suis en
train de me laver les mains la fontaine
du jardin alors il faut bien frotter
partout entre les doigts les ongles et
ne pas oublier les poignets en fait la
peau est recouverte d'une pellicule de
grèce sur laquelle se déposent les
microbes et bactéries et les virus
vous voyez de quoi je veux parler les
molécules qui constitue le cerveau sont
extraordinaires d'un côté elle
s'accroche à la grèce et de l'autre à
l'eau mais comme il y en a davantage
c'est l'eau qui l'emportent et qui en
s'écoulant à rage toute la saleté y
compris les virus mais attention pour
que ça fonctionne
l'opération doit durer au moins 20
secondes le temps de chanter deux fois
joyeux anniversaire alors vous n'êtes
pas obligé de chanter à haute voix mais
ça fait tellement de bien
une vraie capsule 2d confiné aller à
demain et vous connaissez la chanson
nous sommes confinés
mais en restant lien si vous avez aimé
cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à laisser un
pouce bleus gens réalisent une nouvelle
chaque jour alors pour ne rater aucune
de ces capsules 2d confiné abonnez vous
et activer la petite cloche
merci à toutes et à tous et à demain